foreign debut
but it's going to be interesting to see
in this online rapid format how will
he do and here we go the moves are
coming out here we go it's a sicilian
defense i'm not
i'm not sure i expected this one to be
honest firstly rapport opening with the
kingsport doesn't happen every day and
magnus uh now reacting with the sicilian
we're more used to seeing that but it
shows he's in a fighting mood but to do
that as black against such an aggressive
player like report
comes with some risk entails so okay
meanwhile a closed sicilian we're used
to seeing open sicilians at this top
level
the close sicilian may be dropping out
of fashion ever since the days of
spassky the former world champion and uh
okay magnus using a very provocative
style in the opening look at black's
rook on this left side of the board it's
already moved and it's only moved four
or five that is rare at this early stage
and rapport stops the advance of black's
pawns on this left side just by pushing
his own pawn forward one square i must
admit it's nice to see a rapport dressed
in the champion's chest door hoodie uh
in the jacket there it shows he's uh
really really embracing this tournament
and he wants to make his mark yeah and
getting into the spirit of things i feel
and uh magnus really playing very
ambitious chess because
if
if this works out for him he will have
an excellent version
of the traditional lines that you play
against the close sicilian because
normally you know you do get uh this
left side pawn advance but you kind of
don't get it in this particular way you
have to work for it exactly you have to
work for a little bit harder and
also you have to determine where your
pieces on the right side of the board
are going to go here magnus is trying to
be a maximalist he's trying to get
everything he wants and
i'm kind of curious because i must admit
this was one of my favorite openings
when i was younger and okay here comes
the quirkiness here comes the madness
because now we have a move that's never
been seen before surprise surprise and
it's initiating chaos
it's only move six and uh they're in a
brand new position already both players
freestyling rapport he's known for this
he's super creative he's actually got a
very classical upbringing in hungary um
they always teach players the basics
they look at the world champions they
look at all the classic games but he
used that classical training uh to kind
of inspire his creative juices his
creative style and that's why pushing
pawns on both on this left side both of
them now have created maximum tension
and finally white's knight comes in yeah
and i think we'll see white castle over
the next move or two okay he does that
now so white is the first to get ready
and uh we call this the closer cillian
but it might well open up later at the
moment no porn trades no peace trades
that's why it's so close to zillion but
we might well see white try and explode
things open before black is ready yeah
you know you mentioned that uh
richard is from hungary and i don't know
immediately i i thought back to this
conversation i had on a bus a very long
bus ride i had with peter lecko and he
was telling me all about the hungarian
school of chess and it works like this
he says
every hungarian has their openings very
nicely worked out
and if you play perfectly
then it's a draw
because you know everyone played it
doesn't matter who you're playing
against whether they're much lower rated
than your higher rating than you they
play perfect opening draw
however
if you play in inaccuracy in the opening
then the hungarian school of chess says
doesn't matter your rating whether it's
2700 or lower than rate and we play
we play you know because you made a
mistake
and he's really bugged the trend of
hungarian players uh richard rapport
he's far more creative than uh i can
other players i guess in his generation
out there in hungary and um yeah he's
really gone his own way both in terms of
career as well maybe not playing the
tournaments he was expected to and uh
maybe not
i mean now he doesn't live in hungary
but just maybe not following the
expected route either way he's made it
now to the top of world champs about to
qualify for the candidates and meanwhile
magnus playing a move he's got ready to
castle his king
and uh yeah really tense position right
now i'm used to seeing close sicily in
srivanga where white just actually
develops normally doesn't commit on the
queen side and then actually wants to
play an attack against the black king
and you mentioned you played this when
you were young this was one of your main
openings and i know that was the case
for a lot of younger players they start
with this right because the plans are
quite straightforward yeah quite
thematic what do you think of this one
uh using your experience there
yeah this this one is uh quite flexible
i'm not quite sure why i like it because
um the plan that i was kind of taught
was was quite thematic and quite almost
by rote which was like you know develop
a dark square bishop trade off your
opponent's dark squares and then and
only then push forward with these type
of pawn moves um if you're going to do
these type of poor moves you try to be
maximalist about it you know you go the
whole shebang with on the rights you
know just push every pawn you can there
and uh one thing that
every single captain that i've ever
trained me during those years they hated
me playing this particular opening with
the white pieces because they were like
look at your light squared bishop it's
so bad that is the definition of a bad
bishop and i would go
yeah
but i'm not playing anything else
so well we're gonna have to make do here
and uh yeah you know they often grimaced
when they look to my positions but
didn't matter because
you when you play these positions out
you get a feel for them and uh here
richard is actually doing
all the things that you should be doing
you know he's uh taking the
he's bringing the knight into the center
this is also another kind of standard
idea that you get and it's also a
consequence of magnus actually
retreating his knight
yeah and uh finally belatedly magnus
does castle
and uh i'm expecting richard here to try
and trade off these dark squared bishops
there we go
but via an unusual way really unusual
usually you mentioned ivanka the plan is
to actually bring the bishop to the king
side and exchange
black's bishop there but once black's
darts go bishop in front of the black
king disappears there might be holes
around around that black king there
might be some targets for
richard to aim at later so really
interest interesting strategy and there
was actually a big threat in the
position earlier as well with these pawn
pushes to push everything forward in the
center with white but richard he's taken
a slower approach now and he'll wait
before pushing more pawns forward okay
there magnus goes those darts go [ __ ]
all right neutral fiance and that's been
neutralized for both sides and uh 52
minutes left in the auction to bid for
uh our charity chess cup
yes oh and i have to say one thing about
this uh
this cup as a tea drinker i really
appreciate that this is a really good
quality it really is high quality it has
a very thin top to it and it feels okay
anyway yeah anyway it's a really good
cup basically it definitely is it's it's
great quality it's homemade and the
design on the one that is up for auction
is with a beautiful
night homemade by a fantastic designer
in oslo and 92 is the current bid on
this cup 51 minutes left so i head into
cctaaction.com to make your bid all the
money of course go to the fundraiser for
unicef
yeah everything tastes better when
there's a chest piece on the side
there we go yes and meanwhile as well
kai you mentioned the fianchetto
two bishops that were being cathode have
been traded off but look at the
remaining bishops they're both
fianchettoed as well both on the longest
diagonal uh those light squared bishops
now there's a few pieces in the way but
they're kind of staring off against each
other and
i must admit this mysterious move there
by richard rapport tucking his king in
the corner
usually that's a safe-ish idea but here
it stands on the same diagonal as the
black bishop so
slightly surprising also there was no
real danger against the white king the
white knights were really close they're
great defenders
so it feels as if richard he's just kind
of waiting and seeing what magnus what
plan magnus goes for i wonder whether he
has um aggressive intentions and i'm
thinking you know
he's pushed two pawns up to the fourth
row why not have a third join it throw
all the pawns in towards the black and
by moving his king into the edge of the
board maybe he's getting ready for rook
to
move across and maybe potentially
threaten something along the g line
yup possibly it's a long way away i
can't imagine um black's king being in
too much danger yet but it does lack
defenders i guess um so possibly as you
mentioned white's rook sliding to the
square the white king has evacuated
and then throwing pawns towards the
black king i think richard is just kind
of he's not spending too much time on
the clock he wants to save that time for
later he's just staying super flexible
yeah and meanwhile it's not clear what
magnus does because this tension on the
left side of the board
i don't think either side wants to
release that tension um no matter how
you trade you kind of give your opponent
a bit more space
and uh okay magnus
yeah rubbing his eyes there he does that
sometimes is that a sign of something
some calculation or something like that
tiredness
it tends to be in positions where he's
not
kind of feeling too energetic as well
here richard's kind of blocked it up
there's only been a trade of one set of
bishops so it's hard to find a plan for
black and even any plan you go for
doesn't necessarily improve your
position might just lead to some trades
well one plan that they always did
against me in this particular position
was actually to pick up the f7 pawn and
move it two squares forward just to
potentially block up any kingside
expansion
and uh well magnus has decided just to
maneuver and improve his night so still
very tense very exciting stuff yep very
exciting stuff and moving the knights
the black knights now off to this left
side of the board yes they've got some
intentions maybe to continue jumping
forward uh maybe to support some black
pawn pushers on this side but the black
king now completely bereft of any
defenders
so for me a signal of the opponent
moving the knights away from the uh
their king means
we should go for the attack and
man now your idea is your anchor
much more uh much more tempting than
before i don't think you've ever said
that about my porn fishes
normally i've got commitment issues i
admit that openly i don't want to push
like steady or steady or maybe this
approach i'm like yeah okay i like your
approach too yeah
i don't normally want to push forwards
because i'm aware of all the weaknesses
they leave behind but here it's just too
tempting and uh just to show uh one of
your ideas ivanka
one of them is to push this pawn forward
right maybe
once this pawn goes forward later on to
shuffle the rook across onto the same
line as the enemy king and it doesn't
look like much but black's king will
feel a bit uncomfortable and the other
way would be to be even more direct and
just push forward and try to open some
lines immediately open this line for the
rook i'm not sure i would go for this
yet just because it gives black maybe
some control of dark squares in the
center and talking of dark squares
richard decides okay it's not yet time
to throw this pawn forward uh all this
pawn forward instead he just covers
those dark squares this is very logical
as well once you've traded off dark
squared bishops you might as well put
your pawns on dart squares you need some
influence on that color complex and he's
also supporting uh central pawn potion
kaya you like your pawn stretchers if
black just makes a kind of slow move
white is going to push forward with this
one and suddenly there's a lot of pawns
on the fourth rank uh marking their
territory and imagine if black closes
things down we could well see a porn
storm for pawns
the mean girls marching girls and white
just gaining space
black will have to worry about all of
these ideas we haven't seen them in a
while no we haven't seen them in a while
and i got really really excited because
the rook that was looking like it wasn't
doing a single thing
on b2 can suddenly swing across it's
become a rover a roving rook yeah or a
swinging look as
simon williams told us in the last show
so this rook has mentioned yeah it was
doing nothing over here but suddenly if
again flat just doesn't do too much
suddenly if these pieces clear out the
way the rook could swing the whole way
across to the other side of the board
could team up with this other rook and
later on if this line becomes open these
two rooks might well uh be some of the
deciding factors so okay magnus he is
not ready to sit passively and wait for
the white pawns to advance he's doing
the same himself and he's trying to
create his own version there's only
three of them but he's only he's trying
to create his own version of uh of the
pawn storm and
that is a pawn sacrifice he's allowing
this pawn to drop attacking the black
knight at the same time but his idea is
that the knight can cause a double
attack and jumping to the edge of the
board not normally recommended but here
it does threaten the white rook and once
the rook moves it will drop back and
capture at this point so i don't think
richard rapport wants to lose time in
this manner really interesting play it's
all about the pawns right now
they've been a trade of bishops but all
of the pawns still live
and what to do do you take do you block
uh richard report with a huge decision
if he blocks it will become a slower
game white will be committed to going
for an attack against the black king but
you just completely abandoned the center
black can continue pushing forward
himself maybe
but if you capture then suddenly things
might open up and the more things open
up
for example porn takes the more maybe
your king will feel vulnerable on this
diagonal yeah i feel like capturing is
just taboo you don't do it you you're
either going to reinforce the center or
you're going to go forward with your
pawn
and uh
going forward with the pawn yeah i admit
it has its downsides but then again
then again one maybe can get a an active
knight yeah it looks nice at least we
talked about pawn chains uh this is a
nice pawn chain this is a nice pawn
chain it's just maybe too tempting all
of uh white's pawns now on dart square
so it's almost as if he's playing
checkers
and richard report he's very artistic
that's the one thing about him he's one
of the most artistic players out there
he loves these kind of little pretty
patterns these little
nuances uh so i'm expecting as well
javanka as you mentioned just block
things up and maybe this active knight
you also referenced bringing the knight
towards the black king and trying to
plant it into a weak dark square uh this
would be really controversial
it would be really ambitious for richard
report but he is that type of player and
i am i have a message for you david hey
so you know tai are you fantastic stats
guy sitting in uh
it's not washington uh some state
in the u.s
running all our stats with his computers
and uh
um he's saying that if richard report
wins this game
um
he's gonna be up to
2803 wow on the tour ratings he's gonna
pass two thousand eight hundred yeah
okay but he hasn't madness but he has a
big obstacle yeah it has to be the world
champion himself but the bar is on the
side the bars
yeah easier said than done but yeah
definitely yeah 2803
so he will be the second player then to
reach 2800 magnus crossing is of course
um way above 2800 is it
2860 something yeah 2850-ish i think yep
and
richard
i mean i guess in order to become the
king you've got to beat the king so in
order to get 2800 now he needs to beat
the only other 2800 player on the tour
at the moment and what chances do you
give richard report uh you know 96
challenge chance to qualify for
the candidates through the grand prix
and uh if and when he plays what chances
do you give him to qualify for the match
i think he will start as one of the
underdogs but i think he'll like that
there's less he always prefers playing
with less pressure on him uh rickard and
um
yeah it does feel like maybe at the top
level he's one of the least experienced
i mean he's now in his mid-20s
and uh he hasn't played that many elite
events compared to some of the others
for example there will be players in the
candidates who have played world
championship matches before
and he hasn't quite been there meanwhile
he does block it up look at all those
white pawns on dart squares now um
that's
aesthetically at least pleasing but uh
yeah richard he's also the kind of guy
who can beat anyone on his day
one of the interesting things about
richard is that uh unlike the other top
players he doesn't have a team behind
him he's just he has his great support
from his wife javana
definitely but uh really
there's a no other teams to help him he
doesn't have any seconds he does a lot
of his work by himself yeah he's a lone
wolf but that does mean that he knows
all his strengths and weaknesses inside
out and he can be true to his own uh
preferences a lot of top players as we
saw in the world championship match in
the publishing that he ended up playing
openings that his seconds recommended
but it didn't really suit his style so
yeah richard um very much uh individual
player and uh he embraces that and it's
worked well for him at least in the last
couple of years
uh so okay meanwhile a couple of moves
black did try and fight for space in the
center white knight has now gone towards
that black king uh but after a night
jump by black
white's rook was under fire so it had to
take a timeout
to defend itself so yeah it's unclear
who looks happier with their position
it's just that tense yeah this one the
evaluation bar says 0.0 it's still
very very wild this position and
chances for both sides yeah um
i really do like this type of position
because yes black is absolutely
dominating there on the left side of the
board no question you know white is uh
going to go all in with an attack
against the king and as we say and check
in chess checkmate
ends the game so uh definitely the
stakes are high
and of course it's an exciting game
and we still want to be really
enthusiastic about chess so
please everyone
tweet us using the hashtag chesschamps
tweet us your move suggestions tweet us
your comments
and of course as always we love love
love to see your selfies so remember
tweet us using the hashtag and we will
feature them on the show
chess champs
and
yeah i'm struggling to find a move here
for magnus
maybe he has to open things up maybe he
has to trade off some pawns because i'm
getting scared after you mentioned the
word checkmate ivanka i'm kind of scared
the black king has just been abandoned
to its fate and white tonight as we
mentioned is about to jump in with some
nasty checks it needs some backup but if
richard is able to arrange backup for
this white knight on uh sorry on this
side of the board uh then
yeah it's looking scary for magnus and
also remember magnus has already lost
two games in the prelim stage the ghosts
of those defeats might make him a bit
worried here
he lost the last game to david navarro
through a checkmating attack
every time we see him lose i think on
the tour this season last season it
tends to be either through a blunder or
by getting checkmated uh magnus
sometimes he does underestimate the
safety of his own king so maybe richard
is playing with that in mind
and uh yeah definitely no fear from the
hungarians so far
yeah no fear yeah
but you know i i'm also tempted if i
were magnus to actually just step
forward with the pawn
and push it one square and just kind of
kill
anything that's going to happen on the
left side of the board just cut the
board into and then
say you want to attack me bring it on
and okay he doesn't go for this as you
mentioned ivanka now this rook is
eternally locked out of the game this is
a real thorn in white side really far
advanced down the board but then again
white would have ideas of just jumping
in and checking this black king and it's
very much black controlling the left
side white controlling the right side
instead magnus deciding okay this one is
too blocked too locked up and actually
blocked positions rapport does tend to
thrive
just because he's able to
use his creativity with maneuvers uh so
magnus instead opens things up so he's
trying to angle for a potential queen
trade uh now if white takes back with
his pawn i think we'll see magnus love
to trade the queens uh at some point
maybe even now and after a recapture
just try to exchange the rooks too and
at least things would open up and it's
more clear what black's plan is then
again richard if he's feeling super
ambitious maybe he'll see a sacrifice he
could take with the knight he could just
abandon his pawns on this side of the
board and uh instead of capturing back
now these pawns because black's knight
is defending it he's going for it he's
going for the attack um now i was gonna
say white tonight can jump in and look
at these two white knights together they
are aiming towards this black king and
this black king remember no defenders
around it
but
i'm pretty sure computers are going to
hate this they'll find a way to defend
and black can just win a pawn here so
what is magnus carson going to do is he
going to get scared of this attack are
you scared of it ivanka yes i am as well
so yeah i mean just forget about the
computer assessment you know computers
play perfect chess but uh you can
definitely see along the horizon that a
night will find itself on this
beautiful outpost on the f6 square and
if the white queen joins in the game
and joins in the attack you know she
finds herself mysteriously on the h6
square for instance she could somehow
break through to the black king then
that's it it's curtains so
yeah so richard he's basically
abandoning this whole left side of the
board abandoning some pawns maybe even a
piece later on he's just gonna go for
this black king he's got one track mind
right now and that's scary for magnus
it's always scary when your opponent
just doesn't care and they only want to
checkmate you so yeah let's go back to
the players because in this current
position magnus is about to go pawn up
he's going to capture this pawn but
richard is going to throw everything
towards this black king
really really complicated stuff and of
the two players suddenly it's richard
who looks more confident with the two
and okay magnus does indeed grab a pawn
yeah
and uh we're going to see it aren't we
and we are yeah
and at this point of suspense
okay he is going for it okay
oh my god this is like a typical kind of
bobby fischer type of attack you know
bobby
doesn't care about the left side of the
board he's going all in for the
checkmate and this is the type of
position as you mentioned we would have
seen 50 years ago maybe 100 years ago
where we would praise the fearlessness
the romanticism of the attacking player
just giving up the whole left side going
for the opponent's king but in modern
chess
defenders
aren't usually favored by the computer
so
we have seen attacks in the past that
just look fantastic but they don't
really work unless your opponent maybe
does make a mistake and i think that's
what richard rapport has to
rely upon now magnus the computer thinks
he's doing well uh but
wow such a calm move just pushing a pawn
forward one square he wants to use this
rook on the second rank maybe ivanka as
you mentioned that white rook on the a2
square maybe wants to swing across and
help the attack yeah to me it's a
surprising change of pace it just looks
really slow you've said a going for the
attack you might as well say b and
continue throwing knights towards the
black king yeah but he's taken a timeout
yeah
and i was going to use a word that i
know simon our good friend
ginger gm uses all the time he says uh
it's a discombobulating move
confusing
and talking of discombobulation
these black knights are really confusing
me and i'm pretty sure they're confusing
rapport because magnus one of his
knights was attacked he just left it
on pries as we say he left it attacked
the other black knight has joined the
action and look at that white rook on
the a2 square
where's it going to run to it's hit now
by one of the black knights
suddenly i'm thinking that rook doesn't
have too many escape squares that black
knight as well that has just moved
hitting white's pawn in the center of
the board i think rapport's last move
just lost all momentum and we were
praising his fearlessness but maybe it's
backfired already at this early stage
yeah
because in the cold light of the day
black does have a pawn on the a3 square
two squares away from queening
oh you know that can slow white's attack
down a little bit yeah this pawn is
you have to keep an eye on it you have
to keep at least one piece sidelined
stopping it and as mentioned this last
night jump by magnus planting tonight on
this square
hits the white rook and i'm oh i'm gonna
sneeze oh no it's this white rook and it
hits this white pawn uh in the center of
the board that's a double attack and
just really struggling you can't defend
them both
and also one way of that uh black can
neutralize white's potential attack is
also maybe go bishop takes knight yeah
at the right time so for example if this
rook moves exactly i mean firstly you
can just capture this pawn maybe yeah
with your queen but as you mentioned
your anchor you can at least get rid of
one potential attacker by capturing in
the center and uh one night shouldn't uh
shouldn't really
scare you nope it uh it isn't one night
it's two nights at least temporarily for
a report and he's jumped in with a check
i'm expecting to see the king step
forward if you step into the corner then
it's more likely you'll actually get
checkmated on the side of the board for
example as we mentioned if the queen
comes in
and tries to go for your king at least
as magnus has done at least with the
king here
you could maybe use your rook to defend
in the corner you could maybe even just
push a pawn forward and keep things nice
and safe it still takes white four or
five moves to actually create a big
threat and uh meanwhile maybe you don't
have that luxury of four or five moves
your rook is attacked wow rapport just
gambling giving away everything he's
decided
it's not worth saving this rook it's not
worth saving this pawn he's just brought
his queen in and uh okay it's the last
chance for him the computer shows this
doesn't work but is magnus gonna call
his bluff if magnus takes this rook
what is his idea i think his idea is
simply to get a perpetual check and he
wants to just uh retreat his knight give
a check
king steps back to wherever it goes and
then the knight can jump in again and
you're like hey
do you remember that i checked mating
idea it's kind of renewed yeah so maybe
a checkmate in two idea here for white i
don't know if black can stop this in the
current position though black doesn't
have to take this rook yet maybe it's
not running away another move you could
consider is jumping in with this knight
with what we call a family fork it's not
just hitting the queen it's not just
hitting the rook it's also hitting this
bishop uh it's not just a double attack
it's kind of a triple attack and the
reason i'm suggesting this is because
now ivanka if the queen moves because
she's under fire then for example if
black just pushes a pawn there are ideas
of the knight coming back as a defender
that is uh a nasty move david
that wasn't the night you're meant to
touch you're meant to touch the other
night and go on some adventure on the
left side
not get back to the defense of the king
yeah so now this night i mean both rooks
under attack from the black knights it
does look like it's just too much i
don't think white is quick enough it
looks scary with the white queen and
white knight super near the black king
but it's just not quite breaking through
so magnus here if he's calm if he
calculates correctly he'll see that he
is winning uh but you never know okay he
does find this move multi-purpose move
and uh it looks like the world champion
is gonna take this one the attack just
too slow for report yeah
and uh 30 minutes left now 31 minutes
left in the auction for um the night
coffee cup and i have news for you guys
because uh we're now going to put in two
for one in that auction we'll have the
very nice uh night coffee cup and we're
also gonna put in an extra cup uh that
all three of us will sign
yeah and uh the bid current bid is a
hundred dollars and there is uh 31
minutes left to make your bid on
cctauction.com
oh
yeah i'm tempted to bid myself now
they are very nice yeah they are sent me
and
signed by us as well yep so
definitely and you have to remember that
every single penny that uh
is generated by these cups goes to
unicef yep absolutely
so uh yesterday's uh eleven hundred
dollars for the chest high
is
just great money going to unicef
and now the bar just all the way over to
minus carlsen's side in this game
is there any hope for richard report or
is his only hope some sort of a blunder
for magnus he has to hope maybe a
blunder or a mouse slip
blunders are possible especially when
you're on the defending side when your
king is the more vulnerable of the two
it's possible to make mistakes you could
under underestimate a check you could
underestimate maybe a potential
sacrifice to break through to your king
but here
with enough time on his clock i feel
with five minutes it feels like magnus
isn't going to slip he's played
perfectly in the defensive phase so far
he's kind of mixed attack with defense
magnus he's gone on the attack on this
left side of the board with his knights
especially grabbing a couple of pawns in
the process and now he's gone a bit on
the defensive he's put the black king on
a good square and now the black knight
is going to just jump back as a
potential defender so
yeah it's uh it's looking difficult
rapport lifting his queen up one square
oh maybe a bit tricky there may be some
ideas in mind as you've mentioned of the
white knight dropping back with a check
but the other move you mentioned the
defensive resource will end this game
because one of white's
pride and joys those nights it has been
removed now white only has two potential
attackers the queen and knight and uh
faced with several defenders it's not
going to be enough
uh magnus just ruthless and
yeah i think that's uh that's the clinch
of this move because there were some
threats actually uh but magnus had
calculated ahead and foreseen those yeah
he just followed the rules right i mean
i'm sure mark magnus calculated it all
but he was kind of aided by the the rule
that you know when you're in danger
trade off your opponent's attackers and
you have to remember three is the magic
number and there were three potential
attackers brewing and richard
unfortunately had to take a time out to
capture the the bishop
queen and knight's not going to be
sufficient
yeah white for example can step back
with his knight and give check but it's
only going to be one check really
and
magnus here as actually has a choice on
the menu which rook do you capture
both of your black knights have a choice
of rook um
what what would you go for you mako or
would you just kind of be
really cold-blooded and just not capture
either rook because you can maybe
capture the next move
yeah i mean i exactly you have your
choice for a feast so you know those
rooks are
leave them be and instead probably take
time out just to clarify the danger
potential danger around the king
yeah how to do that
um i haven't quite figured out how to do
that well
maybe there might be some kind of pesky
perpetual idea is there
night checking and then going back and
then threatening checkmates let's try
and show this just while magnus tries to
figure out the final touches maybe we
can keep an eye on the players uh
because we might see a reaction any
moment now white white's rook has indeed
dropped and this rook is attacked as
well ivanka mentioned a check but the
problem is the king hides in the corner
and okay this is going to happen no more
checks and also there's tension between
the queens so white's knight i think is
gonna jump back to where it came from
threatening to deliver a checkmate but
maybe black can deal with this in a few
ways and one of them i see is just to
bring the rook across and act as a
defender now white's queen and knight
actually teaming up threatening
checkmate on this square but black can
just defend with his rook and uh i think
we're going to see this this rook acting
as a defender might just end the game
richard might well resign here because
he's simply a rook down and another rook
attacked and let's go back to the
players will we see a result after this
last move this rook move using the rook
as a defender will end the game just not
enough attacking pieces left richard now
he's down a rook and he's down two pawns
and there we go he does resign wow he
resigns after 29 moves